ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BAKER LARGEST BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DODD
DURAZO EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROWTH
HERTZBERG HUESO FURTADO JONES
AIRED LEYVA MCGUIRE MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE REAL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR BAKER AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ SENATOR BAKER.
THANKS AGAIN. CALIFORNIA IS A
BIG AREA. YEAH HOUSE LONGER
ANSWER- JAMES BALDWIN
QUARTERMASTER JOBS IN. GOT
INTERESTED. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
SEE THE ROAD AHEAD YEAH THE
POWER REALLY. GIVE US PASS. HE
WAS GRANTED TO YOU. BOB THE
JUROR. OPEN YOUR CHART WHEN HE-
WE WERE JUST AND HUMAN. NUMBER.
TWO AS WE KNOW IT IS A GOOD FOR
ALL OF. GOT ALL THE SOFTWARE.
WELL STRIVING ONLY FOR THE WE
ARE. YEAH GIVEN THIS DAY WE
MAKE IT THAT TO YOU FOR. WE
WOULD HOPE YEAH. KELLY IS ME IN
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FIVE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. AND. IT IS A
LITTLE. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
MEMBERS- WE ARE IN A LITTLE
DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCE WITH
CALVIN IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK
YOU SPEAK INTO YOUR MICROPHONE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU ARE NOT
RECORDED FOR THE RECORD AND WE
HAVE BEEN SOME MODIFICATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE OF YOU IN
THE BACK HAVE A LITTLE RISER SO
THAT YOUR MICROPHONE IS A
LITTLE HIGHER. BUT MAKE SURE
YOU ALWAYS SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE PLEASE MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE SENATORS GLAZER LA MON
MELENDEZ AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
MORNING SENATORS WELCOME
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS M. NOTICES. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SENATE BILL
SEVEN WILL BE GIVEN A SECOND
READING UPON BEING REPORTED
THIS DAY IN ORDER TO THIRD
READING. AMENDMENT MOTION
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS ACROSS THE
DESK ON FRIDAY SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY FEBRUARY 262-728-2020
ONE. WILL BE ADOPTED PUBLISHED
IN THE RETURN OF THE MEASURES
RETURN TO COMMITTEE. SENATOR
BATES FOR WHAT PURPOSE THE RICE.
MISTAKE. YOU'RE GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE HAVE NO ITEMS
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED SO WE WILL
NOW MOVES TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR TO RISE
UP. THANK YOU AND CHAIRED
SENATE BUDGET BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE FIVE WILL BEGIN
THIRTY MINUTES AFTER THIS
SESSION ENDS IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE THANK YOU FOR UNDER
DORADO SENATOR PORTANTINO. THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN FORTY TWO OH THREE AT
NIGHT- NINE TWENTY SEVEN TWELVE
MINUTES. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO WE HAVE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT SENATOR BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- THE
CONTINUATION OF OUR BLACK
HISTORY MONTH CELEBRATION LAST
WEEK I MADE MENTION THAT ALL
MEMBERS WOULD RECEIVE THE BOOK
THE MISEDUCATION OF THE NEGRO
IS OUTSIDE RIGHT OUTSIDE TO
MARRY LOANS I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL MEMBERS PICK UP THE
BOOK BECAUSE LAST WEEK WE HAD
CALENDARS. A LOT OF MEMBERS DID
NOT PICK UP THE CALENDAR SO IF
YOU DID GET YOUR CALORIE HOW
THE COLLEGE BUT PLEASE GET YOUR
BOOKS THIS MORNING WELL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD. THE
PORTANTINO FOR A PURPOSE THE
RISE HIGH RISE TO CONGRATULATE
JEFF PROPULSION LABORATORY ON
THE SUCCESSFUL LANDING OF THE
MARS ROVER AND EVERYBODY WHO
JOINED IN THE PRESENTATION SO
CONGRATULATIONS CALIFORNIA FOR
MAKING THAT WONDERFUL ROVER
AND- IT'S SUCCESSFUL AND- I
THINK SENATOR PORTANTINO.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR HERTZBERG
CHRISTY RISE BUT- JUST AS
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS TO
CLOSE YOUR CONSISTENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS SENATOR
HERTZBERG THE DESK IS CLEARLY.
WELL GIVEN MY OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY I'VE GOT A THIRTY
FIVE MINUTE SPEECH- AS WE CLOSE
OUT. THOUGH THAT THE SET. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
MEMBERS. UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM
WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WE
MADE. WE CONVENE. MONDAY AT TWO
PM HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND WORK
PARTNER COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME FUTURE NOT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY AT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT
DAY MEMBERS.